[Music]
at the very start of every competition
before the lights in the fandom there is
something truly beautiful
a group of people united in passion
pushing the game they love to its limits
in the hopes that one day their dreams
will be realized
it's a path esports fans are all too
familiar with
since i was 12 13 my plan was to be an
esports athlete
but in the pursuit of every great
competition
there is a darker side to the journey
every competition worth watching can be
bought
when the money starts flowing so do the
bets
this is the story of matches thrown and
careers lost
the story of what happens when the dark
underbelly of professional competition
rears its ugly head a story of kids who
messed up and paid the ultimate price
and an industry that persevered
this is the story of match fixing in
esports
[Music]
as long as you've been able to place a
bet on a pro game of any kind
there's been match fixing and fixing a
match happens
just as it sounds someone has a vested
interest in a game having a specific
outcome
and then pressures the players or
parties involved to manipulate the game
in order to ensure that outcome is
realized
this often ends in the players throwing
the game to capitalize on bets they
themselves made
or for payment from those organizing the
fix
the bottom line is that the boundaries
of competition are broken down
so that people can make money and it's
been happening
for a long time in fact let's go back
to 1919.
eight members of the chicago white sox
baseball team were accused of
intentionally losing the world series
in order to get paid off by a gambling
syndicate
the biggest stage in one of the world's
most established professional sports
was corrupted by match fixing once their
plan was uncovered
all eight players received lifetime bans
and major league baseball hired its
first commissioner
to step in and put out the fire judge
landis delivered his verdict on the
eight black
sox the day after they were acquitted
regardless of the verdict of juries
no player that throws a ball game no
player that
promises to throw a ball game will ever
play
professional baseball the baseball world
was sent reeling and it took years for
it to recover
the chicago black sox as they've
eventually become known
would go down as a symbol of an era ripe
with corruption
it's similar to another era 91 years
later in a world where ball gloves were
put down in place of a mouse and
keyboard
in 2010 the esports scene was a far cry
from the franchised commodified world we
know today
but it was growing and that growth was
fueled by passion and love for games
like warcraft and starcraft
and nowhere was this more apparent than
in south korea where starcraft brewed
war
reigns supreme
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
players like flash and jaedong attracted
large audiences and media attention
it felt like there was nowhere to go but
up but with that attention
came corruption 2010 marked the first
massive match fixing scandal
in esports history on june 9 11 members
of the professional brood war world
were found guilty of fixing matches in
south korea
in the same vein as the infamous black
socks 91 years earlier
these players were approached by korean
gambling organizations
that offered them financial gain in
exchange for throwing games
and a community member by the name of
wax angel posted to teamliquid.net after
rumors that korean players were throwing
matches
first surfaced at the time it was like
super shocking when the match fixing
scandal broke in food war
not just because you know it was match
fixing but it was because it was so
players and not only was it like 11 like
mid-tier players it was
it involved savior who was at the time i
don't want to say like top
five greatest player of all time on
april 10 2010
another tl user named rek rule posted
about the rumors as well
and later allegedly paid locals with
knowledge of the fixing to discuss the
scandal
on may 16 2010 the news everyone had
been waiting for
finally broke
is
11 players were banned from korean
esports association or kaspa tournaments
fined and some even face jail time
and amongst them was a young bonjour not
quite at the level of flash or jaedong
but someone known for his strategic
mastery
and creative gameplay nicknamed the
maestro
ma savior jae yoon was among those 11
players
that were banned
in an era where starcraft was leading
the charge to cement esports legitimacy
11 of its players were cast into
darkness
overnight professional brood war became
worldwide
news but not for the reasons fans had
hoped for
and many saw the scandal as a massive
step backwards
for a young up-and-coming industry
is
it wasn't just starcraft where fixing
was taking place either
that same year there were accusations
thrown at mewtwo king one of the best
smash players in the world who allegedly
threw a match to a friend in order to
manipulate the prize system
and make 300 and then in 2012
mlg didn't award a first or second place
finish to any team at their summer
champs league of legends event
after they found out team curse and
dignitas colluded to swing the results
of the finals
all five members of both teams are
running out the mid lane we see a boot
start
pretty standard items here not really
sure what to make of it
cop does manage to get the shot crumbs
takes him down though crumbs that
well-known
ad player on that top lane saying fishes
will get dropped krum's taking too much
damage off the tower they've got to be
careful they're feeding varys
if this was the real rules they couldn't
go and buy now when they have bought
you know you would have you would have
indeed all right i'm showing my numerous
then yeah but i love the fact that you
are trying to analyze an era and
dignitas take game one
and what a strange game it was indeed 85
66 31 minutes gone thanks for making me
cast an arrow guys
both teams were disqualified and no
prize money was awarded they came in
there and like did you guys think this
was funny you know like this is some
kind of joke
you know you think it's fun and i was
like well it is a game i'm trying to
have fun you know like that's the only
reason i play games
and whatever i'm too much of a troll i
guess
just as these esports scenes all over
the world were trying to grow
these scandals were black marks on their
upward trajectory
just a year later an instance of match
fixing would plague another growing
esports scene
while on a much smaller scale rox
kaspersky's alexi solo berezin
intentionally threw a match against z
rage at the tail end of star series
season 6. welcome to this last game of
this group stages for star series
season 6. solo had placed a bet against
his own team
prior to the match and made sure his
team would lose they actually want to
try to go in with this bcd
it was already very low to begin with
three seconds solo as well
they just went in here today what's
different that i don't want to say it's
impossible for us to come back but
you'll
oh he's so dead why is he standing here
i don't know
rough that's that's rough so still
everything was part of that plan but
solo is going to deny himself to
neutrals i think
if you can it's not gonna happen what's
most memorable about this situation is
that solo would have only pocketed 322
dollars
had he not been caught despite the memes
the community
obviously reacted negatively to the news
and valve held a briefing at ti4
making it clear that anyone involved in
match fixing going forward
would be banned for life in fact that
infamously small sum of money has lived
on in dota 2 history
to this day when someone is playing
poorly in dota it's referred to as a
3-2-2
in reference to that it work incident
they kill him up silent for the visit
ramsey's gonna die we're dead forever
maybe found his moment he baited out
that black hole flawlessly
imagine playing so badly the entirety of
twitch chat
thinks you're throwing the game solo
ultimately received a one-year ban from
starladder
as a consequence for his actions but his
story illustrates something much larger
than that of one match against z
rage in 2013 making a living as a pro
gamer was almost impossible
so while that 322 dollars in retrospect
might not seem like a lot
times were tough there was no rule book
for how to deal with incidents of this
nature back in 2013
but valve eventually weighed in and a
small ban was the result
but of course esports held strong over
the course of the next five years the
community grew
exponentially new games cropped up and
their professional scenes continued to
develop
in 2014 dota 2's the international
offered more than
10 million dollars in prizing three won
the victory
over five million dollars
won by way and the crew sunshine
they are your champions the league of
legends world championship
peaked at more than 11 million
concurrent viewers across
40 different viewing platforms
what an extraordinary world championship
samsung white has had and here of all
places well what a place to do it
in a packed world cup stadium here in
seoul
and counter-strike global offensive had
become the premier fps esport
and cultivated a captivating viewer
experience ladies and gentlemen
16-13 it finally happens
a year after nearly a year two second
place finishes dip
finally claimed the title they are
the champions gamescom 2014.
esports was growing its fans were
multiplying
but as we would soon find out it
wouldn't be able to escape the grip
of those looking to throw everything
away for a quick buck
as esports growth was being celebrated
around the globe one of the most famous
instances of match fixing happened
during the first half of 2014 i buy
power's cs go team
were viewed by many as one of north
america's first opportunities to break
into the upper echelon of cs
they possessed one of the most
phenomenal young talents the world had
ever seen in swag
looking for the kill turns around great
shot on flusher goes for jw you're gonna
pick him off as well great round from
swag so far
now a one on two and swag oh my god
another talented young player in
skadoodle yeah what he does with the awp
is unholy like you should not be allowed
basically he's on the fast track to hell
and a mastermind
in steel there's steel who's been the
criminal mastermind
of the ibp team so far they look to be
one of na's brightest hopes
a team that could compete with europe's
best on the international stage
that is until one game against
netcodeguides.com
on august 20th 2014.
ibp were massive favorites in what was
by all accounts a meaningless sivo pro
match but despite the odds
netcodeguides.com
demolished i buy power are they really
just going to wait the time out right
now
is this really happening oh skadoodle
skadoodle why would i don't understand
jdm with a 3k
that will be a seventh round for netcode
guides but you just
watched your teammate get up from jay
but you
walk out with the bomb and try to plan
it fns is holding the site against steel
though bomb plant
in the a bomb site ct's trying to retake
there goes hayes daze gets one
and then swag gets traded out right
there so now all we have left alive is
days in the j hall he's gonna get
dropped on jdm
ends up getting the shot 3k for fns
only kills on ct side out by power were
dazed in swag
flash goes off they know where he is now
makes a shot and tarik
shuts it down netcode guides beating eye
by power
on season ipp didn't just get beat they
were
outmatched in almost every way their
buys were perplexing
look at this they're actually doing a
strange buy here they're going for a
round two surprise bye
they played with an uncharacteristic
level of passiveness and just looked
like a shell
of their former selves in the wake of
that match esports reporter richard
lewis accused the team of match fixing
the next day in an article the article
cited screenshots between shazam who's a
member of denial esports
and an anonymous person on steam i hit
up my friend who also bets on these
teams and i know he's an overpriced him
boy i'm like yo like
listen like just so just to clarify this
is the guy that you were talking to
right on steam the screenshots i was
talking on steam now
now like the first guy i'm not gonna
throw him on the bus or anything he's
just talking about the match
and like this makes sense you know they
already have a sibo playoff spot
so i helped my friend with the
screenshots this guy's a real life
friend of mine that goes to my school
which is going to be really awkward next
time you see him one of ibp's players
dazed was one of the owners of netcode
guide's website
hey what's up guys this is dave from
nekoguides.com but
since has claimed that he had nothing to
do with the way the cs go team was run
we sponsor them but like i never deal
with them
you know i play and you look like a
different
exactly like i do the content on the
website and things like that like that's
like completely separate
than what i deal with you know like
casey like i literally
never talked to anybody on that team
dazed and steel denied throwing the
match
for months did we ever throw a match
nope
but in november of 2014 they were
removed from i buy power's roster
despite their strong tournament results
like you guys have no idea how hard i
prepared for these tournaments man
like us i seriously watch like i
probably watch like 30 hours of demos
you know and that might not seem like a
lot but it is like the most
boring thing in the world to just sit
there and watch and take notes after
notes after notes after notes in the
short time after some of their best
performances
they removed both of their in-game
leaders in steel and dazed
a move that was just downright strange
they lost
both their callers they lost they lost
steal and based
yeah how is the in-game leader now isn't
it i mean but that's so
that's crazy you just lost both guys who
are
essentially like the alphas like alpha
males of the team the guys who like lead
them forwards to victory
who call the strats who do the research
watch all the demos they're gone
they're gone now they're in talked so
it's going to be really interesting as
good as uh nitro and desi may or may not
be
they're talented players yeah that's the
thing the good players they're good
players they're very good players
they've
got a lot of talent a lot of skills they
need somebody
that initial article didn't make quite
the impact you might have expected it to
but further evidence popped up on an
esea forum revealing text messages
that verified that a fix had occurred on
january 16
2015 lewis published a follow-up article
i buy power had thrown the match in
order to win money
skin betting on csgolounge.com
bro when you played against i buy power
when they threw
were you like what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
no dude i was feeling it
i was literally like that me and josh
were like that like we're giving
ourselves credit and [ __ ] and like
talking about this is our comeback into
the scene but uh
finesse called the throw he literally
said like right after the game these
guys 100
through that but i was like dude you're
[ __ ] crazy this whirlwind of
screenshots and shady dealings
proved that it was all true i buy power
had thrown the match in order to win
money
skin betting on csgolounge.com they used
a middleman who set up the bets for them
it was like a decision that took us like
two minutes to make and we just had no
idea about the repercussions
like we came back from europe the team
was like really dead at that point like
we were
we were like talked about it and we
weren't gonna like resize contracts and
like steel told me
he was gonna leave he told everyone he's
going to leave the team um we were like
yeah we're probably not going to restart
contracts we'll just play out the year
and then i figured out from there and
then you know
all of us are friends with deborn and he
basically was like yeah i do just do it
you know he's like brought up the idea
and we were just like all right [ __ ] it
like literally all of us were just like
all right [ __ ] it what do we have to
lose and 10 days after lewis's second
article was published
valve released a blog post titled
integrity
and fair play in it valve announced that
all seven people involved with the
scandal were permanently banned from
valve sponsored events
we have some interesting information
info
it looks as though some pro players have
been banned by volvo
okay let's say this in short altogether
the information we have collected and
received makes us uncomfortable
continuing any involvement with these
individuals therefore we will be
directing our cs go event partners to
not allow any of the following
individuals participation
in any capacity in valve sponsored
events
could deborn casey foster dazed swag
azk steel r i p
ladies and gentlemen r-i-p and many
third-party tournament organizers
followed suit
the only player who made it out
unscathed was skadoodle although there
are conflicting reports on why
val felt confident leaving him unbanned
to this day the ibuypower scandal has
gone down in esports history as one of
the most public
messy and star-studded stains on the
game's otherwise illustrious history
what happens if we get caught like
nothing like we really didn't
it was just it was like you said a very
impulsive decision but i mean i could
completely understand
why there's so much hate about it it
really just ruins the
integrity of the game my thought process
throughout it and i'm sure my teammates
were the same it wasn't
ruining the integrity of the game it was
exploiting a gambling site
there are still cries for the removal of
swag's ban
as many wish that the young prodigy got
to fulfill his true potential
free swat free swag free swat free swag
free blackstone free breaks on three
brakes
all the best wags someday man they will
free you and you will be like
like a bear flying in the air man
and everyone want to get you in the team
brother all the best way
we've seen a few glimpses of that eye by
power roster's potential
both steel and swag have played in third
party events since their bands
and have shown that they still have the
talent they were once known for
swag in particular has shown flashes of
brilliance and the cries for him
to be freed from his ban have not been
silenced even five years removed
they pre-fire the angle i mean pick you
apart it's what swag the best
free racks and just last year we watched
skadoodle and the rest of cloud9
hoist a major trophy the first time an
american team had ever done so
in one of the scene's greatest underdog
stories i don't really have
much words to say as you know i'm not
crying you're crying stop
there are many who believe these
permanent bans were heavy-handed
and that valve should give these players
a chance at redemption
and i think it's a very sad history that
he can't compete anymore for me it's a
little bit too harsh
for what happened and for being the
first time it ever happened
i understand the consequences understand
how hard it was and how serious
what they did was even lewis himself
reflects with a heavy heart about his
role in the matter
and fixing one meaningless game in sievo
i don't want to break it to anybody
it's not a life ban isn't fair i don't
believe that i didn't sign up for that
and i shouldn't have to feel guilty
because of that punishment
but this time valve made a point about
match fixing
that anyone involved would be banned for
is not going to listen to me because i'm
that [ __ ] scum
who did wrong by the community and
there's nothing i can do
to fix that i would do community service
[ __ ] do work for charities
i would donate to charities i would give
up all my prize [ __ ] winnings to
charities
i would do all that [ __ ] so i could go
through rehabilitation
i [ __ ] up i did bad i'm willing to do
[ __ ] good
but i don't have that opportunity so
valve's not gonna
they're not gonna listen to me they
don't give a [ __ ] about me they're done
with me that's it it's the end
it was brought to their attention that i
did wrong they said we're not dealing
with this
[ __ ] him for life done there's nothing i
can do
i have this negative stigma attached to
me for those of my life
there's no good i can do that will fix
it a stance they doubled down on when
they banned all of aero gaming's dota 2
team for life
in the wake of esports next scandal
foreign
to this day it seems these ibp players
will never play in another valve event
in terms of the bands being too harsh i
mean it's hard to say because i think
you know we haven't had any like super
high profile teams throwing for skin so
in a way it's done its job on the other
hand
you know you would like to see those
guys have had a second chance maybe like
one or two years off that really set
north american counter strike back you
know probably at least
a year year and a half i mean the fact
that you lose
some of the most experienced players we
lost two of our
top three in-game leaders um that was a
huge huge blow that took a long time for
this scene in this community to recover
from
esports has come a long way but there
was still a mountain to climb
to release itself from controversies
like this one
from the ashes of brood war came
starcraft 2 a reinvented version of the
game with a burgeoning esports scene
housed primarily in south korea despite
the success of league dota and cs in the
west
starcraft was still one of korea's most
popular esports
and at the peak of that popularity was
lee leif
who in 2015 was the best starcraft 2
player
on the planet beautiful force field the
hypers beginning to slip around
and hit the immortals less impactful
since there are not a lot of roaches but
the warpers have warped
beautiful move taken to the war prism he
gets us around the links
wow they're they're holding up control
holy crap
what on earth are you not human that's
for damn sure so many failings are
possibly going to connect to these suvs
oh they are chasing them right back up
into the mineral line this could be
huge they're so clumped oh my god
he was one of the most dominant and
widely adored players in the starcraft 2
era and he watched it all slip through
his fingers
in october of 2015 the special
investigations unit of the chiang wang
regional prosecution services
released details of match fixing in
starcraft 2. so somehow
one of the one of the various district
courts in korea
they decided prosecutors there they
decided they would investigate
match fixing and esports they went into
it and they discovered
a really a terrible matrix ring
the report cited arrests of multiple
mid-tier sc2 players who alongside four
middlemen
and two financial backers were arrested
in conjunction with the incident
kespa banned them all for life as with
savior and swag
starcraft 2's greatest star was banned
and worse arrested now we have you know
it's
one is aircraft too we have a savior
life two of the most popular players of
all time
getting caught up in match fixing and
it's just like it's such a uh
just a moral blow but this time it
wasn't just a fine or a ban from
professional play
this time an esports match fixing
scandal resulted in a judge
ruling for prison time they say life
went to jail was he didn't he never
served
uh jail time as part of the sentence he
was detained
not as a punishment but detained like
somewhat as you would detain someone who
was like a flight risk or whatever
you know during a trial so he was
detained but he was not like you know it
was not part of his punishment
to be but yes he was detained for
two odd months according to him
in the years since that last major
scandal in south korea
esports has underwent a metamorphosis
the league of legends scene has
transformed into a world of fully
franchised leagues
massive sponsorship deals and a world of
career players
not just quick cash grabs and now we
have the overwatch league where teams
are representing entire cities
and massive holdings groups are dropping
millions to compete for a slot in the
league
it looks and it feels and it sounds like
the dream
has been legitimized but here we've told
you the story
of how we got here under the lights and
the gaze
of millions a story of a time when the
next paycheck
wasn't always guaranteed and the sharks
were circling
trying to find a way to make a quick
handful of cash in a world of young kids
clicking on heads and that sometimes
shady past
has become clear oh my god
wherever there is the highest level of
competition there is money to be made
and it's a true testament to the
strength of the esports world
that we're here now unscathed
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button